bonsoir messieurs chez merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france sur la
forme déjà ce raid eric sinclair comment
est ce que vous avez accueilli cette
allocution de jean castex
écoutez plutôt plutôt
attendu
j'allais dire une partie de prédictions
catastrophistes
comme j'allais dire comme à l'accoutumée
mais alors pour une fois vu ce qui se
passe dans les autres pays avec le
variant micro non on peut imaginer que
ça soit justifiée pour la nouveauté la
nouvelle année ensuite une série une
série de mesures fin j'allais dire dans
la dans la droite ligne de ce qui a été
la communication du gouvernement depuis
depuis plusieurs mois alors on va
revenir évidemment dans le détail de ces
mesures est ce que ça vous semblait
nécessaire à vous aussi berlare
plaideront cet appel à la vigilance à
l'approché des fêtes de fin d'année
ont ce que je retiens du discours c'est
que
la fermeté qui est introduite et je
crois qu'il était quand même temps de de
responsabiliser les gens il a fait
beaucoup appel à la responsabilité il y
aura la responsabilité dans mon
comportement pendant les fêtes etc mais
la responsabilité des non vaccinés
vad mise en cause enfin de dire avec le
pass sanitaire qui devient un pass
vaccinale on n'est pas très très loin de
l'obligation vaccinale total je veux
dire moi c'est un discours qui est
cohérent compte tenu de la gravité de
cette épidémie je veux dire on n'en sort
pas il ya un nouveau variant celle au
micron qui est très très contagieux mais
qui semble ne pas être trop agressif en
revanche s'il ya une nouvelle variation
parce qu'il y en aura de nouvelles
mutations entier inéluctable et que on a
que chose d'agressif autant qu'on ait le
maximum de gens qu'ils soient vaccinés
un débat va donc être organisé au
parlement c'est ce qu'a annoncé à jean
castex un débat pour transformer le
passe à lithaire on passe vaccinale
seule la vaccination pourrait donc
bientôt être valable l'étau se resserre
sur les non-vaccinés ans frédéric saint
clair
wissant sont encore une fois sans que
chiffres à l'appui on puisse avoir la
justification de ce type 2 de politique
premièrement on a de plus en plus
clairement aujourd'hui acquis le fait
qu'on appelle vaccin quelque chose qui
ne l'est pas c'est un modérateur
d'intensité à la fois modérateur
d'intensité pour les formes graves lui
modérateur de l'intensité aussi pour la
transmission et la contamination c'est à
dire qu'on contamine apparemment on y
moins contaminé une fois qu'on est con
et vaccinés mais on est contaminé quand
même et on transmet moins facilement
mais on transmet quand même et on fait
moins de forme grave donc un intérêt
évident à ce qu'on appelle vaccin mais
qui n'est pas un qui n'est pas un vaccin
et donc qui pose un sérieux problème je
vous donne deux exemples une à une
toutes petites anecdotes personnelles je
me trouve à cannes cet été est captable
à la sortie d'une d'une boulangerie et
se passer de 2 ou 3 mètres chaque table
et puis les personnes non vaccinées à
qui on a demandé le pass d'accès el paso
sanitaires qui ont été refusées qui se
sont levés et qui ont été prendre un
café au petit supermarché casino à côté
qui était bondé 40 45 personnes qui
faisaient la queue et plus de place dans
les allées parce qu'on était en plein
été c'est est surchargé en était à
l'intérieur et là tout le monde rend
tout le monde sort et donc vous voyez
bien que il ya quelque part derrière une
forme de mascarade à laquelle les
français adhèrent de moins en moins puis
ensuite il ya une deuxième chose c'est
que ont réduit de plus en plus c'est
l'annoncé ce soir encore on réduit le
plus en plus le le l'espace le temps
entre deux doses on était au début sur
au premier vaccin sûr mais on fait une
dose on est vaccinés on est tranquille
et puis ensuite il a fallu une deuxième
et puis ensuite on a dit bon pas la
troisième ça sera dans six mois puis
finalement ç'a été cinq puis maintenant
c'est 4 et et monsieur delfraissy a
annoncé la quatrième dose alors que les
français n'étaient pas encore prêts à
avoir la troisième sans parler des
médecins autour de moi dans mon quartier
qui me disent dans voudrait bien
vaccinés mais les deux on les a pas donc
vous comprenez bien qu'il ya autour de
cette question vaccinale un enjeu à la
fois médicale mais sanitaires mais aussi
politique il ya un enjeu de gestion et
cet enjeu de gestion les biens il est
manifestement pas rempli correctement
donc à chaque fois comme durci les
conditions compte un certain nombre de
personnes en faisant pointer la
responsabilité sur ces personnes comme
si aujourd'hui l'explosion des taux
d'incidence sur le variant delta et
l'explosion à venir sur omicron était
responsable du à ce petit pourcentage de
personnes non vaccinées on sait très
bien que c'est pas le cas en réalité on
est simplement dans une dans une logique
politique qui vise à prévenir
l'incapacité de l'hôpital à gérer le
flux de malades actuelle est
potentiellement le flux de malades à
venir il me semble que ce n'est pas
forcément la bonne méthode la bonne
approche bernard plédran qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous vous dites vous de
cette de ce délai qui est donc ramené à
quatre mois au lieu de cinq actuellement
délais de ce rappel antique vide qu'est
ce que ça dit de l'efficacité du vaccin
qu'est ce que ça peut changer
non mais avant de revenir sur
l'efficacité je crois que on peut pas
laisser dire que ce n'est pas un vaccin
c'est le débat qu'on a là c'est un débat
de riches je veux dire quand l'épidémie
a commencé on nous annonce et une
dizaine d'années pour avoir un vaccin
qui sera au point on est arrivé à voir
quelque chose qui marche quand même dans
l'énorme majorité des cas
au bout de moins d'un an veut dire c est
quand on voit l'histoire de la dame qui
s'est fait faire un faux pas ce
sanitaires et qui est décédé à l'hôpital
je veux dire c'est pas une maladie tout
à fait anodine je veux dire le vaccin et
c'est un vaccin protège et le
effectivement on le connaît mal parce
qu'on n'a pas le recul qu'on a avec
d'autres vaccins mais qu'il faille 3 ou
4 2 c'est pas le fond du problème le
fond du problème c'est de protéger la
population française et que on
invariants qui est effectivement envie
une certaine chance il est très très
virulente et très contagieux mais pas
trop agressifs mais quelle serait la
situation si on avait un variant
qu'ils ne répondraient absolument pas au
bac c'est en cours je dire l'heure on
n'est pas dans cette situation après que
le décès le délai soit raccourci comme
on me le demande y est ben c'est tant
mieux parce que
c'est qu'on va augmenter la protection
puisqu'on sait qu'avec la troisième dose
on bouge tous complètement la réponse
immunitaire mais
ça fait partie des données qu'on
acquiert au fur et à mesure de la
connaissance du virus et de la réponse
qu'on a mais c'est pas c'est pas
entièrement illogique le gouvernement le
premier ministre pardon a également
longuement appelé les français à se
faire tester avant de retrouver leurs
proches ces prochains jours
bernard plédran l'autotest on en a
beaucoup parlé c'est l'une des mesures
mises en avant aussi pour multiplier les
assurances de ne pas être contaminé
quand on retrouve ses proches qu'elle
engagerait ce que vous portez sur sur
l'auto test qui n'est pas le test anti
sony qui n'est pas non plus le test pcr
c'est quand même mieux que rien
tout à fait mieux que rien mais le
premier ministre offre beaucoup fait
appel à la responsabilité des sciences
une auto test et qu'il est positif on
sait qu'on va être contaminants on est
content et contaminé mais quand vous
êtes contaminants pour l'heureuse de sa
famille donc ça nécessite effectivement
de prendre des mesures d'isolement
surtout en fonction des gens qu'on avec
nous quand on a des gens très âgés mal
vaccinés ou pas encore vaccinés avec la
3e 2 et qu'on est en contact avec eux
est ce qu'on a le droit de leur faire
courir des risques supplémentaires
j'avais la question l'autre aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on aime ou on habite lauzon
temps qui lui ne veut pas de vacciner à
la fête de noël moi je dis le tout le
temps que les responsables et cette
année on ne m'invite pas car il n'a pas
été question en revanche lors de cette
courte allocution de jean castex de la
vaccination des enfants comment est-ce
que vous l'expliquer
parce que c'est un succès un sujet c'est
un sujet compliqué c'est un sujet
explosif
pour pour plusieurs raisons premièrement
parce que on a fait croire aux français
pendant l'été qu'on allait obtenir une
immunité collective et que
le
se vaccine s était pas simplement se
vacciner pour se protéger soi-même et
c'était aussi se vacciner pour protéger
les autres on savait déjà grâce aux
études américaines nos informations qui
avait fuité dans le washington post que
certains kloster aux états unis sur la
côte est avait montré que les niveaux de
charge virale chez les vaccinés non
vaccinées étaient légaux c'est-à-dire
qu'en réalité il y avait une
transmission qui était à peu près égales
c'est la l'université hopkins aux états
unis assez à ces chiffres là ces données
vous pouvez les consulter ses en libre
accès donc fondamentalement on est parti
sur quelque chose qui était erroné en
disant on va vacciner tout le monde
parce que comme ça on va avoir une
immunité collective ce qui avec un
certain nombre de maladies on a pris
comme exemple la variole est tout à fait
vrai sauf que c'est complètement faux
pour le couvrir encore une fois on est
vaccinés on transmet un des porteurs du
virus il transmet donc à partir du
moment où l'on transmet on se vaccine
plus pour l'autre on se vaccine que pour
se protéger soi même donc il ya quelque
chose de très intelligent à dire aux
personnes à risque vaccinez vous puisque
vous êtes à risque revanche pour ceux
qui ne le sont pas et c'est le cas de la
grande majorité des enfants à quelques
cas compliqué chez les enfants mais en
termes de pourcentage c'est extrêmement
faible c'est presque anodin et donc pour
ces personnes là est bien le vaccin peut
présenter un risque mais le bénéfice
n'est pas là et il ya un certain nombre
de médecins je pense par exemple au
docteur blachier qui s'expriment
beaucoup en ce moment le docteur québec
aussi sur une chaîne chef chez vos
confrères de lci qui explique qu'en
réalité il vaut mieux pour les enfants
laissez le l'enfant contracté le virus
pour développer une immunité naturelle
qui est de meilleure qualité pour tout
un tas de raisons que je ne maîtrise pas
parce que je ne suis pas médecin mais
que eux semblent maîtriser et donc ils
sont plutôt en faveur de cette immunité
naturelle encore une fois parce que le
vaccin ne n'empêche pas la transmission
le premier ministre jean castex avait
dit il ya quelques semaines seulement je
veux vacciner les enfants parce que ma
fille de 11 ans et celle qui m'a
transmis le virus or on sait que ce
vaccin n'empêche pas la transmission
donc vous voyez bien qu'il ya quelque
chose là qui fonctionne pas et dont
à partir du moment où je termine en une
phrase à partir du moment où le le
vaccin ne fonctionne pas pour les
enfants c'est explosif de vouloir forcer
les parents à vacciner leurs enfants
alors on va justement faire réagir le
médecin que vous êtes à bernard plédran
sur la vaccination des enfants c'est la
tranche d'âge 6 10 ans qui est
concerné ce que cela ne présente aucun
bénéfice médical pour eux qu'elle est là
quel est le taux d'incidence qu'il
représente dans les cas de contamination
est ce qu'ils sont un vecteur essentiel
de circulation du virus est ce que vous
auriez été favorables à l'obligation de
les vacciner
je ne suis généralement pas favorable à
une obligation générale comme ça après
moi je vais lui montrer beaucoup plus
modeste que monsieur saint clair dans
cette histoire de virus de kobe 19 et
cetera on découvre des choses tous les
jours moi j'ai dit des choses en début
de pandémie que je ne regrette pas parce
que c'était surtout pourquoi les bons
sens quand je disais aux gens qu'ils
avaient les mains et de porter des
masques qui en avait pas c'était
embêtant mais c'était pas grave pour les
enfants je serai
je suis pas favorable à l'obligation
tant qu'hôtel effectivement il ya des
situations particulières je suis pas
aussi radicale que monsieur saint clair
en disant que le vaccin comme transmet
le virus quand sur le vacciner ou pas ce
n'est pas vrai c'est pas mais mais de là
à ce que les enfants ne soient tous
vaccinés je crois pas que ça soit 1,10
marshall et peut-être que la porte de
sortie pour avoir une immunité
collective passe aussi peut-être par les
enfants pour pour sortir de la crise en
fait un
merci pour ça décryptage bernard plédran
médecin généraliste vous êtes aussi
membre du syndicat mg france merci avoue
frédéric sinclair éditorialiste merci et
à bientôt sur rt france